All right,
well now,
today is obviously a kind of watershed or transition and our syllabus,
you remember we began,
uh,
we began with um,
an emphasis on language where then promising to move to an emphasis on a
psychological matters.
And finally a social and cultural determinants of literature.
So far we've immersed ourselves in notions to the effect that thought and speech
are constituted by language or,
uh,
to put it another way,
um,
uh,
brought,
brought into being by language,
uh,
and that,
um,
that thought it's be speech have to be understood as inseparable from their
linguistic.
Your language here being understood,
uh,
sometimes broadly as,
a structure or a semiotic system.
Now obviously our transition from language determined ideas about speech,
discourse,
literature,
uh,
to psychologically determined,
ways of thinking about,
uh,
discourse,
literature,
um,
has a rather smooth road to follow because the first two authors who borrow from
Freud and understand their project,
uh,
to a degree in psychoanalytic terms are nevertheless a using what is now for us
and extremely familiar vocabulary.
That is to say they really do suppose that this the medium of consciousness to
which we now turn the psyche,
the relationship between consciousness and the unconscious,
they really do suppose that this entity,
whatever it may be,
can be understood in terms that we take usefully from,
uh,
verbal,
thought,
uh,
and from linguistics.
Uh,
Lacalle famously said,
as you'll find next week,
the unconscious is structured like a language and Brooks plainly does agree.
You find you open Brooks and you find yourself really,
uh,
apart.
Perhaps I,
I don't know how well all of you,
uh,
are acquainted with the texts of Freud.
We'll say a little bit about beyond the pleasure principle,
which is the crucial text for our purposes,
but plainly apart from the influence of,
and the idea is borrowed from Freud,
uh,
you'll find Brooks,
writing on what for you is pretty familiar turf.
For example,
he begins by borrowing,
uh,
the Russian formalists distinction in trying to explain what fiction is between
plot and story.
Uh,
I feel that I do ultimately have to cave in and to you that the Russian words
for these concepts,
plot and story are uh,
Sujay and fabulous respectively because Brooks keeps using these terms again and
again.
Um,
I,
I've,
I've explained by embarrassment about,
um,
using terms that I really have absolutely no idea then have the meaning of,
uh,
except that I'm told what the meaning of Ms,
in the books that I'm reading,
which of the same books that you're reading,
but in any case,
um,
since Brooks does constantly use these terms,
uh,
I have to overcome embarrassment and at least at times use them.
Uh,
myself.
There are a little or counter intuitive by the way,
if you,
um,
if,
if you try to find cognates for them in English because you'd think that to Jay
would be subject matter.
In other words,
something much closer to what the forum list mean in English by story.
Uh,
and on the other hand,
you'd think that Fabiola might well be something like plot or friction,
but it is not,
it's just the opposite.
Sujay is the plot,
the way in which a story is constructed and the story is the subject matter or
material out of which,
or the Fabiola is the subject matter or material out of which the [inaudible] is
made.
All right.
And in addition to the use of this,
the,
this,
the relationship between plot and story,
we also find Brooks using terms that are now having read Jaak Epson and demand,
a very familiar to us,
the terms metaphor and Mytonomy.
Uh,
there's plainly a tendency in modern literary theory to reduce all the tropes of
rhetoric to just these two terms,
uh,
when needed,
they back up a little bit and invoke other terms.
But the basic distinction in rhetoric as literary theory tends to understand it
is the distinction between metaphor,
which unifies which synthesizes,
which brings together and metonymy,
which puts one thing next to another by a recognizable,
uh,
gesture toward contiguity,
but which nevertheless does not make any claim or pretension to unify,
to establish identity,
to insist in short that a is B.
Uh,
and these two terms,
as I say,
are understood reductively but usefully to be,
uh,
the essential topics of rhetoric,
and appropriated by modern theory in that way.
Now,
Brooks then,
uh,
uses these terms in ways that should be familiar to us.
As I say,
uh,
we,
we have now been amply exposed to them in reading Jakobson and demand.
So there is a language of language in Brooks's essay,
Freud's master plot,
despite the fact that the framework for his argument is psychoanalytic and that
he has drawn primarily on the text of Freud's,
uh,
beyond the pleasure principle.
So what does he take from Freud?
What Interests Brooks about fraud?
He is,
by the way,
uh,
he distinguished Freud and scholar who knows everything about Freud and is
interested in fact by every aspect of Freud.
But for the purpose of constructing the argument here and in the book too,
it's,
this essay belongs,
uh,
the book called Reading for the plot.
It,
for the purposes of constructing that argument.
What'd he takes in particular from Freud is the idea of structure.
The idea that a,
insofar as we can imagine,
Freud anticipating lock con La call himself certainly believed that Freud
anticipated in the idea that the unconscious is structured like a language in
terms of creating fictional plots in terms of the nature of fiction,
which is what interests Brooks.
Well,
what does this mean?
Aristotle tells us that a plot has a beginning,
a middle,
and an end.
Duh,
of course,
is our response and yet at the same time we can understand a a degree of mystery
in evenings.
Those even so seemingly simple,
a pronouncement of beginning of course,
well,
it has to have a beginning a,
we assume that unless we're dealing with Shahabzada it has to have an end,
but at the same time we might well ask ourselves,
why does it have a middle?
What is the function of the middle with respect to a beginning and an end?
Why does Aristotle say,
as Brooks quotes him,
why does Aristotle say that applaud should have a certain magnitude,
why shouldn't it be shorter?
Why shouldn't it be longer?
In other words,
what is the relation of these parts?
And what in particular does the middle have to do with revealing to us the
necessary connectedness of the beginning and the end?
Not just any beginning or any end,
but a beginning,
which precipitates the kind of logic and an end,
which in some way,
whether tragically or comically,
uh,
satisfactorily resolved that logic.
How does all this work?
Brooks believes that he can,
that he can understand it,
uh,
as we'll try to explain in psychoanalytic terms.
Uh,
so this,
he gets this,
he gets from Freud and he also gets,
as I've already suggested,
the methodological idea that one can think of the machinations of a text in
terms of the distinction that Freud makes,
not in beyond the pleasure principle,
but in the interpretation of dreams,
in the passages that you read for today's assignment,
uh,
taken from that book,
the interpretation of dreams about the dream work.
It's there that Freud argues that two of the,
really the central to mechanisms of the dream work are condensation and
displacement.
Condensation takes the essential symbols of the dream and distills them into a
kind of overdetermined unity.
So that if one studies,
the dreamwork,
one can see the underlying wish or desire expressed in the dream manifest in a
particular,
ah,
symbolic unity,
that's the way in which the dream can vet condenses.
But at the same time,
the dream is doing something very,
very different.
And it's called displacement.
There they're essential symbols of the dream.
That is to say the way in which the dream is attempting to manifest,
that which it desires are not expressed in themselves,
but are rather displaced onto sometimes obscurely related ideas or symbols or
images,
excuse me,
or activities that the interpreter,
that the person trying to trying to decode the dream,
uh,
needs to arrive at and to understand.
So displacement is a kind of delay or a detour of understanding.
And condensation on the other hand is a kind of distillation of understanding
and,
and the extraordinary thing that Freud,
uh,
remarks on as he studies dreams in this book,
published 1905,
by the way,
the extraordinary thing about the way in which dreams work is that there seems
to be a kind of coexistence or a simultaneity of these effects.
The dreamwork simultaneously condenses and displaces Ah,
the that which,
uh,
it is somehow or another,
struggling to make manifest as it's as its object of desire.
Now the first person to notice that there might be a,
the,
well there are a variety of people who notice that there might be a connection
between condensation and displacement and metaphor and metonymy most notably
Jacques Lacan,
uh,
whom,
who Brooks quotes to this effect.
Uh,
and that the work in everyday discourse in what we say,
but also in our dreams and in what we tell our analyst can be understood as
operating through the medium of these two tropes.
Condensation.
In other words,
his metaphorical and its nature and displacement is Matt anemic and its nature.
This placement as the is,
is,
is our,
our Matana me as the delay or a perpetual as we,
as,
as we gathered also from Derrida or perpetual DFL,
loss of signification matter for as they bringing together in a statement of
identity,
uh,
of the,
of,
of the discourse that's attempting to articulate itself.
And again,
we see,
uh,
infection as Brooks argues in his essay.
Again,
we see that these two rhetorical tendencies,
the metaphorical and the Metronomic,
uh,
co-exist work.
And of course you can hear the implicit critique of demand in the background,
uh,
may or may not work in harmony,
may or may not conducive to an ultimate unity,
but nevertheless do coexist in such a way that we can understand the unraveling
of a fictional narrative as being like the processes we see at work in the
unraveling of dreams.
And so it's these two elements that Brooke,
Brooke's is interested in,
in Freud and that he primarily does take from Freud.
Now this means among other things that Brooks is not anything like what we may
spontaneously caricature perhaps as a traditional psychoanalytic critic.
Brooks is not going around looking for Oedipus complexes and Phallic symbols.
Brooks is as is as I hope you can see interested in very different aspects of
the Floridian text.
Um,
and he says as much at the end of his essay on page 1171 in the right hand
column where it says there can be psychoanalytic criticism of the text itself
that does not become,
this is what I'm doing.
He says,
that does not become,
as has usually been the case,
a study of the psycho genesis of the text.
The authors are unconscious.
The dynamics of literary response,
the readers unconscious,
the dynamics or the occult motivations of the characters postulating and
unconscious for them.
In other words,
Brooks is not interested in developing a theory of the author or a theory of
character.
Now,
I don't think he really means to be dismissive of Freud,
he and criticism.
I think he's really just telling us that he's doing something different from
that.
And I would remind you in passing that although we don't pause over traditional
Friday and criticism in this course,
it can indeed be extremely interesting.
Just for example,
uh,
Freud's disciple Ernest Jones,
wrote an influential study of Shakespeare's Hamlet,
uh,
in which he showed famously that hamlet has an edifice complex.
Think about the play.
You'll see that there's a good deal and what Jones is saying.
And in fact,
famously and the history of the staging and filming of Shakespeare,
as you probably know,
Sir Laurence Olivier,
uh,
took the role of hamlet under the influence of Ernest Jones.
Uh,
and in,
in the Olivier production of Hamlet,
uh,
let's just say made it painfully clear in his relations with Gertrude that he
had an edifice complex.
Um,
and,
and again,
you know,
I mean,
there were actual sort of literary texts written directly under the influence of
Freud.
One thinks of Dh Lawrence's sons and lovers,
for example,
in which the central character Paul Morrell,
um,
is a crippled,
uh,
by an Oedipus complex that he can't master.
And the difficulties and complications of the plot or of this kind.
I'm moving closer to the present.
Uh,
an important figure in literary theory whom we'll be studying in this course.
Harold Bloom can be understood to be developing in his series of theoretical
texts,
beginning with the anxiety of influence,
a theory of the author that is to say a theory that is based on the relationship
between belated poets and they're precursors,
which is to say a relationship between sons and fathers.
So there is a certain pattern in and of course I,
I invoked this pattern,
uh,
in arguing that Levy Strauss version of the Oedipus Smith,
betrays his Oedipus complex in relation to Freud.
And so plainly,
Floridian criticism with these sorts of preoccupations is widespread,
continues sometimes to appear and cannot simply be discounted or ignored,
uh,
as an influence in the development of thinking about literature or of the
possibilities of thinking about literature.
Not but the odd,
but the odd thing we're maybe not so odd.
The interesting thing,
uh,
in Brooks is work is that although the text is not there to tell us something
about its author or to tell us something about its characters,
even though character is important in fiction,
and that's what Brooks is primarily talking about,
although it's not there to do those things,
it is nevertheless like an author or a character in many ways alive.
That is to say the text is there to express desire to make,
to put in motion,
to make manifest desire or a desire.
Um,
and that is a rather odd thing to think about,
especially when Brooks go so far as to say that he has a particular desire in
mind.
Uh,
the text,
in other words,
the structure of the text,
the way in which the text functions is to fulfill in some way or another,
a desire for reduced excitation.
That is to say the desire which can be associated with the pleasure principle in
sexual terms,
uh,
and can be associated with the idea of the death wish that fraud develops and
beyond the pleasure principle that I'll be coming back to,
um,
as,
uh,
as the reduce the reduction of expectation that would consist in being dead.
Uh,
and so in these ways,
and it remains to see whether or door to what extent these ways are cooperative
in these ways.
Brooks understands the structure,
the delay,
the Arabesque or postponement of the end one fines in the text to involve a kind
of coexistence of the sort that I've been talking about,
um,
between,
uh,
between relations to the possibility through desire of reducing exit
expectation,
being excited,
reducing exited nation.
Now obviously both dreams and stories don't just express this desire.
They also delay it.
I'm sure we've all had the experience of waking up.
It's,
it's an experience by the way,
which is an illusion.
It hasn't really been the case of waking up and thinking that we've been
dreaming the same damn thing all night long.
In other words that,
that we have just been interminably stuck in a,
in a dream predicament which repeats itself again and again and again,
uh,
to the point of absolute,
total tedium.
Many of the dreams we have,
our neither exciting northern reverse,
but simply tedious,
whatever excitement they may have entailed in the long run.
We feel as we wake up that they go on too long.
Um,
perhaps fiction does have the,
this superiority over the dream work,
uh,
that it's art,
that it structure is precisely the protraction of delay to the,
to a desired degree,
but not unduly beyond,
uh,
that,
that degree.
Uh,
and so,
but it's not just that fiction involves the middles of fiction involve these
processes of delay.
It's that they seem also,
and this is one of the ways the one,
one of the reasons Brooks does have recourse to this particular text of Freud,
they also have the curious tendency to revisit unpleasurable things.
That is to say it's not that it's amid the middles of fiction are exciting.
We love to read,
you know,
we're,
and,
and everything we read is a page Turner.
All do.
They're good.
But the fact is,
uh,
our fascination with reading isn't simply a fascination that takes the form of
having fun.
Uh,
in fact,
so much of what we read in fiction is distinctly unpleasurable.
We wince away from it even as we turn the page.
One way to put it,
uh,
especially in 19th century realism,
which particularly interest Brooks,
is all these characters are just madly making bad object choices.
You know,
they're falling in love with the wrong person.
they're getting there,
they're getting stuck in sticky situations that they cat it,
they cat extract themselves because they're not mature enough because they
haven't thought things through.
Because fate looms over the possibility of making a better choice.
However,
the case may be the experiences that constitute the middles even of the greatest
and the most exciting fiction do have a tendency a,
if one thinks at them from a certain remove,
thinks about them from a certain remove to be run pleasurable.
Why?
In other words,
return to what isn't fun to what is it pleasure and what can this possibly have
to do with the pleasure principle?
Now,
that's precisely the question that Freud asks himself in beyond the pleasure
principle,
a text which begins with a consideration of trauma victims.
It's written at the end of the first world war.
And you should understand this text as not isolated in the preoccupation of
writers in Europe.
Uh,
almost contemporary with beyond the pleasure principle,
our novels written in England,
partly as a result of the making public of findings of psychologists,
uh,
about traumatic war victims as the war came to its conclusion.
Uh,
most of you have read a Virginia Woolf's,
Mrs Dalloway and you should recognize that her treatment of Septimus Smith and
Mrs Dalloway is,
uh,
a treatment of a traumatized war victim.
And Rebecca West,
a contemporary and acquaintance of hers who wrote a good many novels,
wrote one in particular called the return to the soldier,
the protagonist of which is also,
uh,
a traumatized war victims.
So it was a theme of the period,
uh,
and Freud's beyond the pleasure principle contributes to this theme.
Brooks himself likes to call it the text of beyond the or Pr Pla,
the text of beyond the pleasure principle as itself a master plot.
Uh,
in other words as having a certain fictive character.
And it would be,
I think,
extremely instructive to read it alongside the return of the soldier or Mrs
Dalloway for the reasons,
for the reasons I've mentioned.
Okay.
So anyway,
Freud begins by saying the weird thing about these drama victims who am I've had
in my office as they seem in a describing their dreams and even in their various
forms of neurotic,
repetitive behavior,
uh,
they seem compulsively to repeat the traumatic experience that has put them in
the very predicament that brought them to me.
In other words,
they don't shy away from it.
They don't,
uh,
in any strict tents repress it,
they keep compulsively going back to it.
Why is that?
How can that possibly be a manifestation of the only kind of drives I had ever
thought existed up until the year 19,
19.
Namely drives that we can associate in one way or another with pleasure,
with the pleasure principle.
Uh,
obviously,
uh,
you know,
with a kind of,
with a sort of implicit socio biological understanding that the protraction of
life is all about sexual reproduction.
Uh,
and that the,
the,
uh,
um,
displacement or,
or,
uh,
or inhibition of the direct drives associated with that take the form of the
desire to succeed,
uh,
the desire to improve oneself,
the desire to become more complex emotionally and all the rest of it.
All of this we can associate with,
uh,
the pleasure principle.
How does this compulsion to return to the traumatic event in any way correspond
to or,
or,
uh,
or submit itself to explanation,
explanation in terms of the pleasure principle.
So then he turns to an example in his own home life,
uh,
is a little grandson,
little Hans,
uh,
standing in his crib,
throwing a spool,
tied to a string out of the crib saying walked away,
not there,
and then post reeling it back in and saying,
doc,
not,
there it is again,
forked Da.
Why on earth is little Hans doing this?
Well,
Freud Pretty,
pretty quickly figures out that what little Hans is doing is finding a way of
expressing his frustration about the way in which his mother leaves the room.
In other words,
his mother is not always there for him.
So what does this act,
what does this,
this,
this play or accomplishing?
He's got her on a string,
right?
Sure.
She goes away.
We have to understand this.
We know our mother goes away,
but guess what?
I can holler back in,
you know,
and there,
and there she is again.
Uh,
and this is the achievement of mastery.
As Freud puts it in books,
files the achievement of mastery that we can acquire through the repetition of a
traumatic event.
So maybe that's the way to think about it,
but it can't just be the achievement of mastery alone because nothing can do
away with or undermine,
undermine the fact that part of the drive involved seems to be to return to the
trauma that is to say,
to keep putting before us the unhappy and traumatic nature of what's involved
now.
So this the,
the compulsion to repeat,
which of course manifests itself in adults in various forms of neurotic
behavior.
By the way,
we're all neurotic and all of us have our little compulsion's.
Uh,
but it can get serious in some cases.
And,
and,
and the composer,
the compulsion to repeat,
um,
takes the form,
uh,
Freud argues,
to the,
the,
of,
especially if we think of it in terms of an effort at mastery to master in
advance through rehearsal as it were,
the inevitability of death,
the trauma of death,
which awaits and which has been heralded by traumatic events in one's life,
uh,
near escape,
for example,
in a train accident or whatever the case may be.
And so Freud,
uh,
in developing his argument,
eventually comes to think that the compulsion to repeat has something to do with
a kind of repeating forward of an event which is in itself and meritable the
event of death,
which is a,
of course that which,
which ultimately looms.
Now it's in this context,
it's in this context that Freud begins to think about how it could be that the
organism,
a engage itself with thoughts of this kind.
What is this,
uh,
almost eager anticipation of death.
And he notices that in certain biological organisms that can be observed.
This by the way,
is,
has,
has been wildly disputed by people actually engaged in biology.
Uh,
but it was,
um,
a useful metaphor for the development of Freud's argument.
He noticed that there is in certain art organisms,
a wish to return to a simpler,
an earlier state of organic existence,
which is to say,
to return to that,
which isn't just what we all look forward to,
but was after all that which existed prior to our emergence into life,
the relationship between the beginning and the end that I've been intimating,
in other words,
is a relation of death.
I begin inanimate and I end inanimate.
And Freud's argument is that there is somehow in us a compulsion or a desire,
a drive to return as well,
like going home again or going back to the womb to return to that inanimate
state.
The aim of all life.
He then says,
ah,
his death.
Well,
no,
maybe,
maybe the important thing is to,
is to allow Brooks,
uh,
to comment on that so that you can see how he makes use of Freud's idea and move
us a little bit closer to the application of these ideas to the structure of a
literary plot or a of a fictional plot.
So on page 11,
66 and the right hand margin,
uh,
the beginning of the second paragraph,
a Brooke says,
we need a president to follow Freud into his closer inquiry concerning the
relation between the compulsion to repeat and the instinctual.
The answer lies in a universal attribute of instinct and perhaps of organic life
in general,
that an instinct is an urge inherent in organic life to restore an earlier state
of things.
Building on this idea.
Page 1169,
the left hand column about halfway down
the function of the drives.
I mean,
he says this function,
but the function of the drs is concerned with the most universal endeavor of all
living substance,
namely to return to the quiescence of the Inorganic World Cup.
Got a pleasant,
I guess,
right?
And,
uh,
the desire to return to the quiescence of the organic world.
The aim in this context,
in this sense,
the aim of all life is death.
But there's more,
and this is why novels are long,
not too long,
not too short,
but of a certain length of a certain magnitude.
As Aristotle puts it,
there is more because the organism doesn't just want a die.
The organism is not suicidal.
That's a crucial mistake that we make when we first tried to come to terms with
what Freud means by the death wish.
The organism wants to die on its own terms,
which is why it has any labyrinth mechanism of defenses.
The outer Cortex,
as Freud is always calling it,
attempting to withstand,
to process,
to keep an arm's length,
the possibility of trauma.
You blame yourself as a victim of trauma for for not having the sufficient vis
vigilance and your outer cortex to to ward it off.
Part of the compulsion to reteach to repeat is in a certain sense to the the
mastery that's involved.
The hope of mastery and the compulsion to repeat is to keep up the kind of
vigilance which you failed to have in the past and therefore fail to ward it off
so the organism only wishes to die on its own terms.
If you are reminded here by the passage of 10 Yanoff that I gave you where he
makes the distinction between literary history as evolving and literary history
is modified by as modified by outside circumstances,
I think it would be a legitimate parallel.
What the organism according to Freud wants to do is evolve toward its
dissolution,
not to be modified,
not in other words to be interfered with by everything from external trauma to
internal disease.
It doesn't want that.
It wants to live a rich and full life.
It wants to live a life of a certain magnitude,
but with a view to achieving the ultimate desired end,
which is to return to an inorganic state on its own terms.
And so there's this tension in the organism between evolving to its end and
being modified prematurely toward an end.
A modification,
which in terms of fiction would mean it wouldn't have a plot,
right?
You might have a beginning,
but you would have,
uh,
you would have a sudden cutting off that prevented this,
the arabesque of the plot from developing and arising.
Uh,
now what Brooks argues following fraud is that to this end,
the creating of an atmosphere in which with dignity and integrity as it were,
the organism can progress toward its own end,
uh,
without interference as it were.
Uh,
what Brooks following Freud argues is that in this process,
the pleasure principle and the death wish cooperate,
uh,
page 11,
66,
uh,
bottom of the right hand column and then over to led and 67,
a relatively long passage.
Um,
hence Freud is able to proffer with a certain bravado,
the formulation,
the aim of all life is death.
We are given an evolutionary image of the organism in which the tension created
by external influences has forced living substance to diverged ever more widely
from its original course of life and to make ever more complicated day tour
before reaching its aim of death.
In this view,
the self preservative instincts function to assure that the organism shall
follow it's own path to death to ward off anyways of returning to the inorganic,
which are not imminent to the organism itself.
In other words,
the organism wishes to die only in its own fashion.
It busts against events,
dangers,
which would help to achieve its goal to rapidly by a kind of short circuit.
And again,
uh,
on page,
on page 1169 lefthand column,
a little bit farther down from the passage we quoted before,
Brooke says,
we could say that the repetition,
compulsion and the death instinct serve the pleasure principle in a larger sense
though the pleasure principle keeping watch on the invasion of stimuli from
without and especially from within seeking their discharge serves the death
instinct,
making sure that the organism is permitted to return to quiescence.
And it's in this way that these two,
uh,
these two differing drives,
co-exist and in some measure cooperate in the developing and enriching of the
good life and in the developing and enriching of the good plot
and obvious problem with this theory and Freud acknowledges this problem and
beyond the pleasure principle is that it's awfully hard to keep death and sex
separate.
In other words,
the reduction of expectation is obviously something that the pleasure principle
is all about.
The purpose of sex is to reduce exercitation to anol desire.
The purpose of death,
Freud argues,
is to do the same thing.
Well,
how can you tell the one from the other?
There's a rich,
there's a rich vein of literary history,
which insists on their interchangeability.
We all know what to die means in early modern poems.
Well,
no,
about the about Lebus tote and Tristan does,
and he's older,
uh,
the moments of death,
in literature,
which obviously are sexually charged,
uh,
there is a kind of manifest,
and knowing confusion of the two,
uh,
in literature.
And Freud always says that the poets preceded him and everything that he
thought,
uh,
which suggests that it is rather hard to keep these things separate.
For example,
by the way,
um,
you know,
the compulsion to repeat a nasty episodes,
the to revisit trauma,
uh,
to repeat the unpleasurable well that could just be called masochism couldn't
it,
it could be called something which is a kind of pleasure,
uh,
and which therefore could be subsumed under the pleasure principle and would
obviate the need for a theory of the death drive as Freud develops it in beyond
the pleasure principle.
Now,
Freud acknowledges this,
he says that it is difficult to make the distinction.
He feels that that a variety of sorts of clinic,
clinical evidence at his disposal warrant the distinction,
but it is not an easy one and it's one that I suppose we could continue to
entertain as a kind of skepticism about this way of understanding,
uh,
of,
of understanding the compulsion to repeat,
uh,
as somehow necessarily entailing a theory of the death wish.
All right,
now quickly as to the plot,
desire emerges or begins as the narrative.
What is the unairable?
The unairable is that immersion in our lives such that there is no sense of form
or order or a structure.
I mean,
anything is on narrative will.
If we don't have a sense of a beginning and a middle and an end to bring to bear
on it,
the narrative will and other words must enter into a structure.
And so the beginning,
which is meditated on by soft Chris Rock town in and Jose and quoted to that
effect by Brooks on the left hand column of page 1163,
the narrative will begins in this moment of entry into that pattern of desire
that launches a fiction.
We have speculated on what that desire consistent.
And so the narrative will becomes a plot and the plot operates through metaphor,
which unifies the plot,
which shows a,
the remarkable coherence of all of its parts.
A narrative theory is always talking with some satisfaction about how there's no
such thing in fiction as irrelevant detail.
In other words,
nothing is there by accident.
That is the metaphoric pressure brought to bear on plotting by sort of in the
course of composition.
Uh,
everything is there for a reason.
And the reason is arguably the nature of the underlying desire that's driving
the plot forward.
But on the other hand,
metonymy function functions as the principal of delay.
The detour,
the Arabesque,
the refusal of closure,
they settling upon that object choice and other unfortunate outcomes.
The return of the unpleasurable,
all the things that happen,
uh,
in the structure of middles,
in literary plot.
The plot finally binds material together.
Both metaphor and metonymy are arguably forms of binding.
Uh,
page 1166,
uh,
the right hand column,
bottom of the first paragraph,
Brooks says to speak of binding in a literary text is thus to speak of any of
the formalization,
which like binding may be painful retarding that us to recognize sameness within
difference or the very emergence of eight Sujay from the material of Fabiola.
Okay.
Now I want to turn to Tony as a,
an instance of the way in which reading for the plot can take place.
Um,
but I,
and I also want to mention that the choice of these materials for today's
assignment,
uh,
is not just a way into questions of psychoanalysis as they bear on literature
and literary theory,
but also adjust your towards something that those of you whose favorite form of
reading his novels may wish we had a little more of.
And of course,
of this kind,
namely narrative theory narrow otology.
Uh,
and I commend to you the opening pages of Brooks is essay where he passes and
review some of the most important work in narrative theory work good.
I mentioned in passing when I talked about structuralism a couple of years,
a couple of weeks back,
seems like years,
doesn't it?
Uh,
and uh,
and work,
which is for those of you who are interested in narrative and narrative theory,
you may well wish to revisit,
we'll unbox say Tom total rough gerage Jeanette,
uh,
are the figures,
to whom Brooke,
Brooke's is primarily a expressing indebtedness within that tradition.
But anyway,
Tony,
the tow truck,
I would suggest that,
uh,
in the context of beyond the pleasure principle,
we could,
we could retitle Tony the tow truck as the bumpy road to maturity.
Uh,
it,
it certainly has the qualities of a picker fiction.
It's on the road as it were.
Uh,
and it's the linearity of its plot.
The way in which the plot is like beads on a string,
which tends to be the case with picker ask fiction.
And which by the way is also a metta Nimic aspect of the fiction.
Uh,
the linearity of the plot.
Um,
Lens,
the feeling of picturesque to,
to the narrative.
Um,
uh,
quickly to reread it.
I know that you all have it glued to your wrists,
but in case you don't,
uh,
to reread it,
I am Tony the tow truck.
I live in a little yellow garage.
I help cars that are stuck.
I told them to my garage.
I like my job.
One day.
I am stuck.
Who will help Tony?
The tow truck.
I cannot help you.
Says Neato the car.
I don't want to get dirty.
I cannot help you.
See these are bad object choices,
right?
I cannot help you said speed either car.
I am too busy.
I am very sad.
Then a little car pulls up.
It is my friend,
bumpy,
gives me a push.
He pushes and pushes.
And I'm a,
by the way,
uh,
this,
this text I think very close to its surface,
a kind of anal phase parable in that,
in that parable,
the hero is not Tony in fact,
but a character with whom you are familiar,
if you're familiar with,
with a South Park.
Um,
and that character is of course the one who says he pushes and pushes.
And I'm on my way.
Uh,
but,
but in any case,
that is part of the narrative.
Uh,
and then thank you.
Bumpy.
I call back.
You're welcome.
Says Bumpy.
Now that's what I call a friend.
So that's,
that's the text of Tony the tow truck.
Now we've said that it's picker ask.
Um,
we can think in terms of repetition,
obviously,
uh,
as the delay that sets in between and origin and an end.
Uh,
and we've spoken of this as in this case.
well it's the triadic form of Folk Tale of that Brooks actually mentions in his
essay.
Um,
but it is in its dilation of the relationship be beginning of beginning an end,
a way of reminding us of the,
of,
of that precisely of that relation.
He comes from a little yellow garage.
The question is,
and a question which is perhaps part of the unairable is,
is he going back there?
We know he's on his way,
but we don't know if we read it in terms of beyond the pleasure principle,
whether he's on his way back to the little yellow Varage or weather and there's
a premonition of this and being stock,
in other words in having broken down,
uh,
whether he's on his way to the junk yard.
Uh,
but in either case,
uh,
the only point is that he will go to either place because little yellow garages
that from which he came,
uh,
that in either case,
little yellow garage or a junk yard,
he's going to get there on his own terms,
but not as a narcissist,
not as the person who begins every sentence.
And the first part of the story with the word I,
because you can't just be an autonomous hero on your journey.
And this is also true of the study of folklore on your journey.
You need a helper,
you know,
that's part,
that's part of fiction.
You need another hero,
you need a hero to help you.
And having that hero and countering the other mind,
uh,
as helper,
is what obviates the tendency toward even in a nice guy like Tony,
the tendency toward narcissism,
which is manifest in the eye at the beginning of the story.
Notice that then the,
I disappears.
Not completely,
but wherever it reappears,
it's embedded rather than initial.
It is no longer in other words,
that which drives the line in the story.
And so,
and then so,
so the Arabesque of the plot,
uh,
as I say,
as a matter of encountering bad object choices and overcoming them,
neatness,
buisiness,
you know,
choices,
which by the way are on the surface.
Temptations.
We all want to be neat,
busy,
don't wait.
But somehow or another,
it's not enough because the otherness,
the mutuality of regard,
uh,
that this story wants to enforce as life,
as life,
properly lived,
uh,
is not entailed in and of itself in neatness and buisiness,
resolution and closure then is mature object choice.
Um,
and um,
and yeah,
and in a certain sense,
um,
there are two,
it's a push forward,
but we don't quite know,
uh,
toward what we have to assume though in the context of a reading of this kind.
That's a push toward a state in which the little yellow garage and the junkyard
are the unairable junkyard are manifest as one and the same thing.
Now as Matana me the delays we've been talking about,
the paratactic structure of the way in which the story is told,
all of that,
uh,
and the elements of repetition,
all of that,
our forms that we recognize as met anemic.
But there's something beyond that at the level of theme.
This is a story about cars.
This is a story about mechanical objects,
some of which moved,
because remember those smiling houses in the background,
some of which move.
Uh,
and some of which are stationary,
but they're all mechanical objects.
They're all structured.
In other words,
they're not organic.
This is a world understood from a mechanistic point of view as that which lacks
organicity and yet at the same time,
the whole point of the story is the magically metaphoric.
It is to assert the common humanity of us all.
That's what I call a friend.
The whole point of so many children's stories,
animal stories,
stories like this little engine that could,
is to humanize the world,
to render friendly and warm and inviting to the child,
the entire world so that Tony is not a tow truck.
Tony's a human being and he realizes humanity interacting [inaudible] the
existence of a friend,
the unity of the story.
In other words,
as opposed to it's metronomic displacements through the mechanistic,
the unity of the story is the triumphant humanization of the mechanistic and the
fact that as we read the story,
we feel that we are after all,
not in mechanical company but in Human Company.
That's the effect of the story and the way it works in terms of the pleasure
principle.
Then life is best in a human universe.
And in terms of,
well,
in terms of beyond the pleasure principle,
the whole point of returning to an earlier state,
little yellow garage junk yard is to avert the threat.
That one being stock.
We'll return to that junk yard prematurely or along the wrong path.
Okay,
so next time we will turn to the somewhat formidable task of understanding lock
comb.